et
[Musique]
les shadoks à grosse tête ont laissé
leurs trois chefs en plan et continue
tout seuls dans leurs costumes autobus
sur la terre les gy be ont enfin compris
qu'ils ont attrapé une terrible maladie
[Musique]
c'était la maladie de la terre qui fait
mourir les choses et les gens une
maladie que les jbe ne connaissait pas
car il venait d'une planète où le temps
n'existait pas ou plutôt le temps allait
et venait d'un côté et de l'autre de
sorte que c'était toujours les mêmes
djiby qui sert les cheveux qui n'avait
pas ce genre de problème là il y en
avait pas mal qui périssaient mais il y
en avait aussi pas mal qu'ils essaient
et quinquas avec des hauts et des balles
dans l'eau très bon an mal an la
population shadoks aller plus ou moins
sont chez les jb malheureusement ce
n'était pas prévu la seule façon de
guérir c'était de rentrer chez eux mais
vite sans quoi il serait trop tard légis
bigras tombe bien que mal s'entassent
dans leurs fusées le cosmo cole 999 est
activé et la fusée jbe et la fusée jbe
et l'apaisé gilles bineau parc
il était drôle ou pas beaucoup trop
lourd mais trop lourd tout de même on a
beau si j'avais un g20 comme il est
d'usagé en pareille occasion il fallait
bien tirés au sort qui allait rester et
le sens tomba sur un gimmick que vous
avez oublié peut-être le jpy qui
autrefois avait perdu son chapeau dans
l'espace et était de nous ou à cause de
cela mais le hasard fait bien les choses
car ce jbe faut justement n'avait pas
attraper la maladie de la terre et tout
laissait à penser qu'on y restant il
vise et puis je gêne promis que de toute
façon il s'en occuperait et la fusée jbe
parti et le parti
mais lentement lentement mais au fur et
à mesure qu'il s'éloignait et que la
planète jbe approchait leur vie un poil
petit à petit disparaît c'est quand il
arriverait peut-être se retire thierry
tout à fait
[Musique]